is a young nepali artist based in
kathmandu her work is part of a show by
five artists entitled poems from home
that explores ideas of identity culture
and space the exhibition is part of the
kathmandu trianali 2077
nepal's biggest arts festival that runs
throughout the month of march
i like to explore how the mobile phone
and digital technology impact
traditional cultures and our daily lives
which then create a new culture
[Music]
this fourth edition kicked off in
kathmandu on the first of the month
after being postponed several times due
to the pandemic
spread across three historic areas in
the city and five exhibition venues it
features 300 works by local and
international artists
it includes diverse art forms like
multimedia photography paintings and
installations and offers guided tours
and online viewing
shirari badritsarya is a festival
organizer she says her team intends to
show how the art community in nepal has
grown
the curators of this edition
have worked
is about
trying to weave very complex narratives
about issues around gender or queer
bodies or you know indigenous
expressions and in mapping and gardens
and what are these narratives around the
way we see colonization work and how we
see power work and how do we
sort of dismantle some of the ways we
perceive these things
through artists works it's very powerful
the works are in contrast to the
mountain landscapes and religious
paintings visitors often associate with
nepal chirin sherpa used to create
tibetan buddhist paintings called tankas
today he gives the art form a
contemporary take one of few nepali
artists to feature in prestigious
international platforms like the venice
biennale sherpa looks forward to the
kathmandu trinali
it's a wonderful experience and let's
see
let's hope that we can
introduce nepal in a different light
than what we have been understood so far
through our works we're at the paragon
museum a venue for the kathmandu trinali
the works displayed here celebrate the
diversity and explore the connections
between local and global communities
while they reject the exoticization of
the himalaya as a mythical utopia as
nepal's vibrant art community grows
artists say it's important to continue
conversations between traditional and
contemporary art forms to present a
realistic portrait of nepal today
ramyatha limbu al-jazeera kathmandu